[Musica]
scrivo e trony tri band e cassino
per certi tutte quante perché un nuovo
furia di desiderati
vedo scrivere
e tu poni ridotto a uno scrittore
bello godere
la barba pizzi che questa camicia se ne
andrebbe
per in tintoria da sola
se potesse
farei io ma non posso non adesso credo
scrive
[Musica]
l'amore
per scrivere
[Musica]
bene
cosa
[Musica]
le mans
domani
le rime
[Musica]
melita
serve
prendermi
e ridicolo
ora
[Musica]
ebbene mi chiedono spesso come si fa a
fare questo andare in giro per l'italia
a suonare la propria musica e lo
chiedevano insomma e rispondevo sempre
bene suonando in giro più possibile ma
ti ho appena chiesto come si fa a
suonare in giro
ciò intendo bisogna desiderare
fortissimamente andare in giro a suonare
per cui andare a cercare i palcoscenici
anche dai palcoscenici non ce ne sono
proponendosi gratis dormendo in macchina
andare a fare i concorsi ni uscire dalla
propria città la propria provincia
poi ovviamente uscire dopo aver suonato
in tutti i buchi del tuo paese in tutte
le strade giovani e bar maretti questo
questo approccio mira a due risultati
essere seminali per cui trovare un
pubblico e provare a piantare in
qualcuno un germoglio qua che cresca e
lui diventa un amplificatore della tua
opera per cui parla della tua musica ad
altri per cui magari il concerto dopo
invece che tre persone ce ne sono sei
l'altro risultato è quello sul piano
dell'esperienza la formazione che uno
riceve facendo quel tipo di percorso è
impagabile stare ore in furgone
con la puzza di piedi dei tuoi amici
arrivare in posti sperduti aspettare
l'una di notte personale avanti a
quattro gatti dormire in bettole
mangiare il mangime per musicisti che i
locali tengono i sacchi da 50 chili
sotto il bancone
dopo due o tre anni così sicuramente ti
sei fortificato è veramente hai imparato
un po del mestiere oppure torni
all'università a finire di prendere
quella laurea che avevi lasciato in
sospeso
tra muscoli e cervello pianterà una
seria
vogliamo in venere un giorno senza
muovermi per dimenticare la mia
educazione
prenditoriale cercherò il coraggio di
sentirmi inutile la forza di restare
immobile per debiti
potenziare voglio fare
non senza freni
voglio fare
nord del mondo di chi stare bene
[Musica]
da fare
di chi sta
insomma per cui andare in giro stare on
the road
suonare in tutti i buchi anche per poche
persone si fa così no no non si fa più
così e nel giro di qualche anno
lo scenario è cambiato completamente
metà degli anni dieci i social hanno la
loro esplosione definitiva e quelli di i
giovanissimi che c'erano nati dentro e
sapevano benissimo come muoverci si
volevano fare musica cosa facevano si
registravano il brano anche il video
visto che i costi ormai erano
accessibilissimi e poi si
interfacciavano con i loro simili erano
online ottenendo dei numeri pazzeschi da
subito e con quei numeri si rivolgevano
direttamente alle grandi etichette che
li mettevano sotto contratto
nello stesso periodo chi era come me per
esempio già operativo sulla scena è un
veterano però si era trovato per le mani
anche lui il sociale per cui se c'era la
capacità di usare con lo strumento lì
anche appartenendo all'india underground
si ottenevano molta visibilità anche
perché si era tra i primi a creare
contenuti per quelle piattaforme
la musica è sempre stata centrale non
nel nell'era digitale
per cui anche questi soggetti
acquisiscono una bella visibilità e
crescono molto le agenzie di booking e
quindi si ritrovano per le mani questa
no questa realtà e mettono i primi i
giovanissimi dimettono sui palcoscenici
già con cachet da professionisti e fanno
aumentare anche i cachet degli artisti
underground cosiddetti indie
come si fa a far crescere i cresce di un
artista 1 diciamo di metodi
preferenziali e polarizzare gli eventi
per cui piuttosto che cinque concerti da
100 persone è meglio farne uno da 500
piuttosto che quattro concerti da 500 ne
facciamo uno da da 2000
diciamo che meno male queste insieme ad
altre concause hanno stravolto lo
scenario economico della del panorama
underground italiano in quegli anni un
artista che lo stesso tipo di artista
che nel 2010 girava a 1 nel 2016 girava
a 5
[Musica]
soffro più di vertigini da che sono
caduto a prezzo pieno
mi sono rialzato pieno i lividi e rossa
per guarire la paura del vuoto proprio
per guarire la paura del vuoto
[Musica]
d'acero
e non cari
però
[Musica]
o
e scampia
[Musica]
e i baretti dei baretti in tutto questo
cosa capita di barrette vivono
esattamente questa esperienza
pochi anni prima intercettavano per 300
euro
una futura star della musica italiana
adesso non hanno più questo
interlocutore perché questo
interlocutore avendo follower virus e
like cerca di piazzare direttamente sul
mercato ovvero la sua musica in scala
subiscono lo stesso destino tutti i
piccoli eventi feste della birra feste
parrocchiali sagra della porchetta noi
io la mia band appunto nel 2009 2010
2011 abbiamo incontrato colleghi il
punto in sagra del tartufo che qualche
anno dopo avrebbero fatto i palazzetti
questa cosa adesso non succederebbe mai
e ovviamente è un circolo vizioso perché
se il fermento smette di stare per
strada la strada si disabitua a
contenere e di incontrare il fermento
per cui la gente si disabitua
a uscire di casa e imbattersi
casualmente i musicisti di talento
talento grezzo però talento e lo saprete
benissimo quando si incontra un talento
vero succede qualcosa dentro non si
torna a casa in questa cosa si riverbera
in quello che andrai a fare pensare
immaginare qualcosa di contagioso
se invece si vuole mettere subito
l'artista sul palco grande sì si
amplifica il gesto ma si perde la
contagiosità della vicinanza che invece
si sviluppa negli ambienti che vidi
scrivevo prima per cui non so io l'ho
visto succedere a volte l'ho vista l'ho
fatto anche accadere questa cosa una
volta ero a parma suonavo in un caffè
che aveva messo medi fuori i tavolini e
c'era una signora che stava rientrando
nel portone che praticamente era di
fianco a questo caffè mi ha sentito è
tornata indietro se messa in platea e
poi dopo lo spettacolo evenutali era al
p ta male è bravissimo ma chi è chi non
è qui qui sotto casa mia incredibile e
bellissimo si è bellissimo
gli studi non ti abbassi a perdere la
regione non attacchi per fare male non
si certe parole non ve lo posso fare ora
posso fare perché devo devo stringere
devo stringere
io pensavo sempre pensato di avere un
mestiere antichissimo per le mani
tramandato nei secoli negli alti e bassi
della storia
ho sempre pensato se arriva un asteroide
cade sul pianeta viene spazzata via la
civiltà
io andrò e tra i fumi della distruzione
della distruzione e con cantando una
canzone rimedierò un piatto di minestra
questa cosa pensavo il mio mestiere
pino che è arrivato il copy che lo ha
spazzato via nel serino intesi male ha
spazzato via la situazione ora la
conosciamo tutti e lo spettacolo e la
musica in italia sono il segmento che
forse ha capito di più e sta patendo di
più anche nella ricostruzione i grandi
eventi in questo momento sono azzerati e
sono insostenibili sono in programma
bili sono in continua procrastinazione
per cui c'è un vuoto silenzioso
immagino che a questo punto stiate no
sappiate già dove voglia andare a parare
cioè come si fa a risolvere questo
problema che non si può neanche dire
problema perché i grandi comunicatori ci
insegnano che la parola problema va
sostituita con la parola opportunità una
volta mi si è fermata la macchina e ho
chiamato il meccanico gli ho detto ciò
un'opportunità con la mia macchina anche
sul telefono in faccia e l'opportunità
secondo me e ripartire dai piccoli
eventi cioè facciamo non si possono fare
i concerti con tante persone facciamo
molti concerti con poche persone
ripartiamo da questo facciamo diventare
le nostre città dei contenitori di una
miriadi di piccoli eventi
ritorniamo nei bar a mettere 10 sedie e
uno che suona nei cortili dove volete
voi per strada dove si possono ammettere
56 l'insicurezza facciamo uno spettacolo
perché è una risorsa enorme quella del
circuito dei piccoli eventi che che non
si deve spegnere io personalmente ho già
cominciato l'anno scorso ho messo il mio
pianoforte in macchina ho dimezzato il
mio cachet e sono andato da tutti quelli
che volevano organizzare un concerto
fatto consulenza a chi non aveva mai
fatto un evento voleva farne uno per
ripartire con qualcosa e se arrivavo in
dei posti non c'era il palcoscenico
rimediamo il pallet facevamo una cosa al
volo con i cavi e siamo ripartiti da lì
conto di fare la stessa cosa
quest'estate
nell'attesa che uno dei mestieri più
antichi del mondo superi anche questa
prova della storia grazie a tutti
[Musica]